scholars have long argued about whether
the plays of William Shakespeare were
written by others
they've also debated whether it is more
difficult to write an original
screenplay or to adapt to him from other
work whatever Wow nominees for the best
screenplay based on material previously
produced or published are Eric Roth for
Forrest Gump based on a novel by Winston
groovy
Island Bennett from the madness of King
George based on his stage stay the
madness of King George the third Robert
Benton for nobody's fool based on the
novel by Richard Russell well and now
CEO for quiz show based on the book
remembering in America Washington
citizens but it should have been Goodwin
Frank element for the Shawshank
Redemption based on short novel with
redemption I sleep in and the Oscar goes
to air across from Forrest Gump
I don't believe this well I'm gonna
shorten my speech considerably
three-hole paper
I'm a very lucky man I'm just blessed
lucky to have an agent like the sublime
Jensen Dale lucky to have a dear friend
and producer like Wendy finer man who
met move mountains lucky to work for
Paramount Studios Sherry Lansing jungle
we're gonna write his best friend
Michelle Manning lucky to have the
majestic actor Tom Hanks a gay forest is
hard his memorable voice and such great
dignity lucky to have the remarkable
director Bob Zemeckis who gave Forrest a
sense of humor it's irony and style in
the simple eloquence lucky to be the son
of Mimi and Lianne Roth or up there
somewhere who gave him their love for
movies and their love for life lucky
dude I've known Linda lucky to have all
my wonderful children growing straight
and tall Vanessa and Mark and Joshua and
Juliet the great Samantha my boy
Geoffrey and little Alec and lucky
and lucky to be married to the bluest
eyes around Deborah Greenfield it gives
me so much joy as and always keeps me
honest
to paraphrase Forrest a new a good thing
when he saw it I may not be the smartest
man around but I know what love is
I sure do thank you